we're told kaya rode her bicycle toward
a tree at a constant speed the table
below shows the relationship between her
distance to the tree and how many times
her front tire rotated so once her tire
rotated four times she was twenty two
and a half metres from the tree then
when she's rotated eight times she's
twelve and a half metres from the tree
when it rotated twelve times then she's
only two and a half metres to the tree
so she's getting closer and closer there
are more rotations that her tire has had
so then they asked us some questions
here so they asked us how far away was
the tree to begin with how far does kaya
travel with each rotation how many
rotations did it take to get to the tree
so like always pause this video and see
if you can answer these questions on
your own before we do it together so
let's start with the first question how
far away was the tree to begin with so
the way that I would think about it is
after four rotations we're 22 and a half
metres from the tree we see that if we
increase by another four rotations so
let's see plus four rotations we see
that we have gotten ten meters closer to
the tree or our distance to the tree has
gone down by 10 meters it's alright
negative 10 meters here if we want to
figure out how far the tree was to begin
with
we have to go back to 0 rotations so if
we're going back by 4 so we're
subtracting 4 from the rotations and 4
going at a constant rate well then we
would add 10 meters so we would add 10
meters if we add 4 rotations we get 10
meters closer if we take away 4
rotations to get us back to 0 rotations
then we will go 10 meters further so
that would be at 32 point 5 meters so 32
point 5 meters is how far the tree was
to begin with when Kara had 0 rotations
the next question is how far does kaya
travel with each rotation all right well
we already saw that with 4 rotations
she's traveling 10
meters so we could say 10 meters in 4
rotations so if we divide both of these
by 4 what would we get well that's the
same thing as two-and-a-half meters in
one rotation so this is 2.5 meters and
last but not least how many rotations
did it take to get to the tree well we
know that after 12 rotations she's only
two and a half meters away from the tree
we also know that in every one rotation
she gets two and a half meters closer so
she only needs one more rotation to
cover this next two and a half meters so
if we go plus one rotations we're going
to go down two and a half meters we're
going to go two and a half meters closer
to the tree and we will be at the tree
so how many rotations did it take to get
to the tree in total 13 rotations now
one thing that's interesting is to think
about what we just did in a graphical
context that you might have seen before
and if we were to put on the horizontal
axis rotations and if we were to put on
the vertical axis distance to the tree
distance to tree I'll just call the
vertical axis the y axis and the
horizontal axis the x axis well we could
see here that we have 0 4 8 12 I could
go to 16 and then we saw that at 0
rotations we are 32.5 meters from the
tree so 32.5 this is all going to be in
meters so this first question was really
another way of asking what is our
y-intercept and this next question how
far does kaya travel with each rotation
well we saw that when you increase
irritations by 4 your distance to the
tree goes down by 10 meters so when this
is +4 we went down we went down 10
meters so it's negative 10 meters so
really what we were thinking about right
here this is
could think about the magnitude of the
slope the slope of this line the slope
of this line that would describe her
distance to the treat as based on the
number of rotations the slope is going
to be our change in our distance which
is negative 10 for our change in
rotations over 4 so the slope of this
line is negative two point five meters
per rotation but when they say how far
does KY travel with each rotation she's
getting two-and-a-half meters closer her
distance goes her distance from the tree
goes down by two-and-a-half meters and
this last question how many rotations
did it take to get to the tree well at
what point is our Y value our just it to
the tree zero and we saw that it is at
13 rotations so this is another way of
thinking about what was the x-intercept
so the line and it's a line because we
know that she's traveling at a constant
rate looks something like that
so they really were thick asking us the
y-intercept the slope and the
x-intercept